bienvenue à tous ce nouvel épisode
d'envergure on va parler de la sensation
française du moment
je ne veux pas parler de barbara praveen
interprète de l'eurovision d'une 21 qui
va nous représenter nous la france mais
bel et bien de yoann makoun d'où le
joueur de cholet sur ce magnifique
introduction jamais lancé le générique
et accueillir tous les chroniqueurs
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
en fait on fait des podcasts comme dans
les années 70 donc romain est la
bienvenue romain mon papa de basket club
de radio crochet on en est presque là
oui c'est ça c'est ça la chance aux
chansons
robin manu à la n'sele également ici ça
lui est le spécialiste territoriale
venue de la data team passion doit
encore l'appeler la data team j'ai envie
de les appeler les spécialistes
régionaux justement les alors si je peux
me permettre si les spécialiser
territoire pour garder une wii voilà
c'est vrai c'est vrai que tu as raison
tu as raison les territoires sont
importants il faut associer les
territoires et donc pierre est avec nous
salut pierre a fallu alors johan
backlund où on explique rapidement mais
il a explosé au mois de janvier
c'est assez simple avant c'était un
prospect français donc il est né en 2000
c'est un prospect français j'avais dire
comme un autre non pas comme un autre un
peu plus athlétique sans doute mais
voilà qui avait pas percé et là d'un
coup les rayons au premier plan et il
commence à faire un petit peu de bruit
parce qu'il est athlétique parce qu'il
est grand temps pour plein de raisons
qu'on va vous détailler dans ce podcast
donc on va voir si ba voila il y avait
des chances et la drave quels sont ses
points forts ses points faibles et pour
une présentation assez rapide
je vais demander évidemment à romain qui
a en plus jouer contre lui
strasbourg a joué deux fois pendant le
mois de janvier où il est un peu chaud
c'est exactement ça on la joue et on l'a
joué deux fois au mois de janvier
bon là je vois une première fois en
coupe de france
que je retrouve la date ça devait que le
9 janvier de mémoire où il sortait 4/10
quasiment son ne sont plus jugés hier de
son match en carrière récent le plus
convaincant contre la la sémillante
équipe de du dessous qui minsk vous avez
passé une petite 18 points 9 rebonds
dont trop rebond of dernière à ses
propres contre nous sur ce match-là il
astarté mais finalement on a concédé
c'était un jour sur lequel on a vu un
focus un petit peu particulier parce que
mon à une équipe qui était assez forte
au rebond c'est un jour à contenir non
content ou via un petit peu un petit peu
restées en demi-teinte ce qui fait
finalement le match le plus qu en dire
le moins le moins efficace qu'il ait eu
ces derniers temps c'est contre nous
puisque en fait même sa mise à part il a
enchaîné donc je vais vous faire un
rapport chiffré grave in 22 minutes 14
points 7 rebonds contre nous sommes en
match de championnat il ya un petit peu
plus une petite semaine 19 points 5
rebonds en 23 minutes et en coupe
d'europe dont kominsky et 18 points 9
rebonds et contre l'hapoel d'olonne
toujours en bcl 27 minutes 20 points 8
rebonds
donc pour pour le présenter rapidement
ses bruts de décoffrage mais mes brut
ces brutes quoi c'est à dire c'est
plutôt brutal si on fait pas attention
c'est un joueur très athlétique qui doit
être un petit peu plus de 2 mètres ils
votent à 2,02 quelques jeux d'eau 3 2 4
peut-être ice & cie les listes et à 6
nice 6 nous faire un des 1 200 rage est
la douane entre 2,6 et 2,7 selon les
sites
voilà moi je vais devoir mettre à deux
on va mettre à 2,5 doit être pas si l'
on le met à 2,5 vieillissement à jouer
pas donc j'ai pu y de paye depuis on est
on est assez enders en dessous et donc
c'est vrai que steve oui c'est vrai pas
de point de comparaison c'est un peu ce
qui fait notre charme mais c'est
vraiment brut de décoffrage c'est un un
joueur un joueur atypique jeu par
rapport au profil de poste 4 qu'on a
aujourd'hui parce que il n'a pas
forcément une grosse capacité à tirer
loin c'est pas séparemment dans son adn
et dans son jeu
c'est un joueur qui vont cas de l'impact
défensif
une vraie une vraie machine un gros
moteur et puis qui en attaque tout ce
qui va être au dessus du cercle en
général c c'est assez facile pour lui
c'est un joueur qui joue vraiment au
dessus du cercle et qui est assez assez
rapide explosif et très dense
s'il y avait une limite aujourd'hui pour
moi ce sera plutôt dans la capacité à
enchaîner des actions avec le ballon
c'est à dire que tout ce qui va être
posée la balle sur les hanches et les ce
n'est pas forcément ce qui fait mieux
après sur le tir extérieur ils tirent
peu son tir est pas forcément si si
dégueulasse que ça parce que sur le
catch and shoot bon il a il n'a rien mis
aujourd'hui andy pettitte parce qu'ils
tirent très peu mais sur lequel shoot à
mi distance il est capable de tirer un
petit peu la short corner et je vois
j'ai le souvenir km deux tiers sur l'a2
dire dans le short corner c'est vraiment
ouvert si vous faites l'impasse il va il
va il va il va prendre le tir à 3 mais
c'est pas aujourd'hui s'il fait mieux
c'est à dire que pour moi une vraie
variable de la marge de progression de
ce côté là au demeurant il est quand
même à 71% ont lancé ce qu'il laisse
avoir un peu d'espoir sur cet aspect
aujourd'hui manière abrupte
un joueur qui en championnat en
championnat - dans un contexte sur le
tech et pas qui n'est pas forcément très
facile ces derniers temps où il a peu
joué cesser ses stats sont pas forcément
très réductrice de son impact à 15
minutes 7 points 75% à 2 points quand
même en championnat 70 % de points bcl
ça vous situe un petit peu l'efficacité
du bonhomme près du cercle
mais ce qu'il faut tenir compte des
statures mois de janvier je pense pour
lui parce que ce qui s'était passé après
je suis allé un peu navigué à vue avec
avec covile de blessure surcharge
joueurs étrangers et cetera et cetera
donc c'était pas forcément un contexte
très simple pour rajeunir
mais là aujourd'hui il a installé dans
la dans la rotation il ay la star télé
les derniers matches de manière très
convaincante donc bah oui quand j'ai
envie de dire pardon tant mieux pour
cholette alors justement le contexte
pierre qui t'intéresse de très près au
jeune français qui évoluent en jeep
élites notamment
quel est son rôle dans l'équipe quel
joueur il ya autour de lui
qu'est ce qu'on lui demande en fait est
là il est en train de profiter de la
dynamique qui a eu à l'intérieur d'eux
pour à l'intérieur de la raquette
choletaise en fait il ya pas mal de
joueurs qui arrivent qui s'en vont comme
colas dieu romain donc il a profité en
fait pour monter dans la rotation ils
gagnent des minutes en plus en
confirmant il a la possibilité de jouer
aussi une coupe européenne donc en
baisse elle est donc là il essaye de
s'imposer c'est il est à la lutte pour
être le meneur pendant le le poste 4
titulaires voilà il est il en train de
gagner sa place au fur et à mesure dans
une équipe qui a pas forcément commencer
la saison d' une même bannière andy
pettitte là ils sont à 3,6 sur sur la
saison il joue le il joue là ils sont
deux sur le bas tableau mais ils sont
dans le dans un championnat où ils sont
à deux victoires du premier qualifiable
en clair après une nécessaire et chez
moi ils ont les deux tours et de colin
hanks qui excepté un petit peu aussi le
problème de leur retard à l'allumage et
là il bénéficie aussi à l'heure actuelle
du fait que
christopher horton la cata graminées qui
est revenue et quand même pas dans un
dans une dans une forme olympique
puisqu'il a été malade et ainsi de suite
donc ils bénéficient à l'heure actuelle
de ces minutes là pour ça que le
contexte aujourd'hui pour lui et quand
même et quand même très favorables
malgré les difficultés relatives sportif
choletaise
et malgré tout je nuance 1 on n'a pas
tous la même dans nos matches
aujourd'hui on a joué on sur les on a
joué on a joué je crois de moins que
nous donc que je suis allez vous leur
mettez deux victoires de plus si on
porte des playoffs aux portes des 50%
termes d'éthique et donc c'est c'est la
situation sportive à l'instant t je
pense que l assez difficile à lire sur
la jeep élite ce qui ce qui compte
surtout c'est l'ombre de défaite lui qui
peut avoir parce que s'il permet d'avoir
une espèce de perspective d'une part et
d'autre part il ya vraiment le cas
particulier de l'effectif comme drogba à
l'heure actuelle horton est pas est pas
encore revenu à son meilleur niveau donc
bayonne makoun ou en profite pour
continuer dans le contexte qui a autour
de lui qu'elle quel genre d'intérieur
avec quel genre d'intérieur il va faire
la paire en fait on va l'aligner il va
jouer le plus de minutes
bah c'est là il est en fait seule chose
cholet un jeu un jour il n'ya pas
effectivement pas de 4 au large
c'est un petit peu c'est un petit peu
quelque part le ils trouvent leur espace
d'une autre façon il essentiellement
associé à ron jones quel poste cinq
pistes qui start en fait nan t'as dit
rajout plus forcément énormément bon
fofana prend deux minutes et un petit
peu en alternance est pareil le temps de
jeu a tendance à baisser hier que si
vous voulez mesurer leur actuel l'impact
de l'yonne makoun sur cholet sur sur le
rendement il suffit de regarder les
minutes des gens qui habituellement joué
sur le poste 4 ou qu'ils pouvaient jouer
en rotation sur le poste 4
les deux premières les deux premières
entre guillemets victime de sa montée en
régime
ces lits minutes qui conclut que l'on
t'a diarra n'a plus que je fais ça
fofana n'a plus aujourd'hui parce que le
joueur aujourd'hui il est totalement
rentables
absolument alors peut-être qu'on peut
ajouter
il ya quelques stats avant c'est là
qu'ils seront quand même assez parlante
sur son efficacité à l'intérieur c'est
le premier c'est le premier de tous les
hauts pourcentages de rebond offensif
est aussi le meilleur sur une équipe
pour le pourcentage de
faute de chute boké et c'est le
quatrième de la ligue avec devant lui il
la chi chi coco et mon frère sa place
quand même le seul coup ça ce sont les
stats lnb dont une boîte coupe de redjeb
les stats
donc ok donc de lempdes sur l'ensemble
de la saison coupe d'europe justement va
passer sur sur ses points forts qu'on a
bien compris finition un cercle à cercle
et protection du cercle mais on peut
rentrer dans le détail manu qu'est-ce
qui sait faire et qui va pouvoir faire
peut-être plus haut niveau puisqu'il
joue déjà en jeep élite et coupe
d'europe ce qui est pas mal mais il n'y
a que 20 ans
bah c'est ouais c'est la tare du cercle
où il va être super intéressant je
trouve que là dessus c'est rarement le
son avantage et des deux côtés du
terrain il est super intéressant proche
du cercle il est pas encore un très bon
rim protector mais c'est pas forcément
son rôle non plus à cholet c'est parce
qu'on vend le plus mais bon pour moi
c'est vraiment ça c'est sa capacité à
être fort à l'intérieur notamment en
attaque et après ce quinté intéressant
chez lui ça va être ça son potentiel
parce qu'il a plusieurs points qui peut
vraiment améliorer et ça peut vraiment
lui apporter des minutes au fil de sa
carrière
alors de quoi tu parles précisément moi
j'ai sur ce qui peut améliorer si
l'obtention son shoot comme l'a dit
romain il est il assez intéressant sur
le catch and shoot s'il est vraiment
tout seul
donc oui il va en rentrée il prenait
l'exemple de de son match contre la sig
où effectivement l as huile un quart de
terrain où il est rarement tout seul il
sanctionne directement et là dessus
s'ils arrivent à négocier de plus en
plus il a de plus en plus de ballons
comme ça dans ce rôle là je pense que ça
peut tout de suite devenir une arme
supplémentaire il va pouvoir écarter la
défense et ensuite justement revenir sur
son point fort qu'elle attaque du cercle
et ça c'est super intéressant il sauf
que justement cour a contrario il va
très très peu de swing des lancers
francs
aussi seulement tatler tentative en jeep
élite
et dix centièmes pink cloud donc ces
on-dit qu'il est bon proche du cercle
mais au final ils prouvent pas non plus
beaucoup beaucoup de fautes donc ça ça
il peut aussi améliorer ça va le rendre
encore un peu plus plus meilleur ça
c'est intéressant j'aimais sa capacité à
demeurer dans le trafic il a pas peur
d'eux voilà deux fous des bretons mars
il a ici il faut quand même s'il ya deux
jours devant lui il va souhaiter il va
mettre le ballon en deux en quoi donc
aussi pour ça que c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il n'y a pas trop de fautes puisque
les gens s'écartent il s'écarte pas tout
le temps il ya un truc aujourd'hui on
sait je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec toi sur le côté elle protector
parce que au jour d'aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est peut-être pas
nécessairement
sa force première en revanche je peux
vous faire une capture d'écran de la
tête tête dam des joueurs qui s'est pris
un qui s'est pris un agent serait
peut-être alors qu'ils remontaient il a
un tel ligue 2 contre l'unification du
corps qui est super intéressante et
croyez moi ils ne comptent peut-être pas
beaucoup me dissuader ils dissuadent
vraiment oui les gueux normativement on
ne bouge pas facilement il une vraie
longueur une vraie dimension et il monte
lite
après le fait qu'il provoque pas
beaucoup de fautes je suis assez
d'accord avec toi
seulement c'est pareil je vais me lancer
un petit peu le truc si tu regardes les
matchs où les dix minutes
à une exception près il est toujours
allé à peu près correctement sur la
ligne le là-dessus faut savoir une chose
les jeunes joueurs andy pettitte quoi
vous prouver pour avoir des coups de
sifflets il faut vraiment vraiment
vraiment qu'ils prennent des cours c'est
vrai les jeunes voleurs un peu comme en
nba les jeunes devant sont quand même
très rarement récompensé chose que j'ai
jamais compris parce qu'à un moment ou
un autre un joueur est un joueur quel
que soit son âge et moi là dessus c'est
un petit peu quelque chose qui me gêne
après il va peu au cercle
au cinéma il veut pour sa part une diva
peu sur la vie aussi pour une autre
raison il bénéficie beaucoup la création
d'euro bat et de stockton non jeu
dangereux comment dire de cholet il est
parfois la finition dans les situations
et de se retrouver seul dans du jeu sans
ballon près du cercle
ou alors allez attraper des lobes à des
moments où des mecs ne sont surtout pas
chercher à lutter pour paître sur les
photos donc quelque part je il pourra
l'y plus sur la ligne tout à fait
d'accord mais juan ça parce que
aujourd'hui il a il a eu quasiment plus
de plus de lancers a tiré sur les deux
derniers matches du dip élite il en a
tiré 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 sur les six matches
précédents il en tire ayant attiré 5
oui il ya des progrès peut-être que manu
sur le le le
le côté rim protecteur protection de
cercle défensive
tu voulais peut-être aussi parlé du côté
être à l'heure dans les aides quoi
puisque il n'y a pas que le timing de
saut il ya aussi la lecture défensive
des aides à apporter quoi moi j'ai sur
après puis je suis d'accord sur ce qu
d'accord avec roman sur le fait qu'il a
une super et l'ombre a déjà voilà j'aime
bien ça intéressant ça peut aussi le
projeter à défendre un peu à l'extérieur
même s'il n'ya pas je trouve qu'ils
oublient un peu défensivement il a
tendance à se cacher derrière son
défenseur
que ce soit en attaque ou en défense il
sait pas trop où il est des fois il a un
peu il un peu perdu mais ça va venir je
sais écouter un sur un des matchs comme
commentateur des tic au filet il a
commencé le basket ya seulement cinq ans
donc il a encore en plein en plein
apprentissage donc ça laisse de beaux
jours devant lui comme alan je vais te
donner la parole en utilisant une de tes
expressions favorites
on parle là d'un joueur de doute chaîne
de cinq chaînes comment tu imagines plus
haut
qu'est ce qui lui manque pour être
efficace je sais pas dans une top team
euroligue voir en nba pas le tir et
savoir avec quels types d'intérieurs il
va jouer et ça ça va je pense drivée par
sentir en fait parce que plus on est
payé lui-même en euroligue maintenant on
sauf le real madrid qui des fois jouent
avec un spécial que douteux mais yann ya
que h1n1 shooter par paria par équipe et
je parle pas vraiment de réussite mais
je parle plus de volume en fait il faut
que il et quels joueurs prennent des
tirs qui refuse pas les ir est en fait
si marine d'eau il prend pas de tir il
devra jouer
il devra je post 5 je pense ou alors il
devra jouer avec un poste 5 vraiment
strech ce qui se ferait du bien comme
bouc lopez ou maxi kléber par exemple
qu'on appelle moi je pense qu'il faut
vraiment qu'ils travaillent s'est passé
sus
tir extérieur / / du catch and shoot sur
du 15 octobre inclus
je pense que c'est sera c'est un vrai
jour tu fais comme tu l'as dit il est
super verticale il est super tonique
donc la finition proche du cercle et les
mots ce que j'aime surtout c'est qu'il
arrive c'est super bien j'ai
l'impression à se placer pour en
transition pour être servi dans de
bonnes conditions il suit le passeur
voient leur coupe la ligne au bon moment
ils tiendront ce qui comprend bien la
situation sur du jeu rapide
après sur le jeu demi terrain des fois
il est placé un peu dans le match que
j'ai vu contre l'équipe que mentionné
romain signé kim publié l'origine je
crois lizeroux minsk
ouais c'est ça qui me plaît le russe il
est souvent fait dans le joker spot donc
c'est à dire comment expliquer il est
ligne de fond c'est au bord de la
raquette intersection raquette ligne de
soul exactement entre la ligne à trois
points et là la ligne de lancer franc
la voilà la barre devant ces fonds est
donc en fait c'est là il est utile parce
que si il ya un des cages avant lui et
qu'il autres intérieurs le voit il est
servi et lu et que ça qui passait de
finition ben ali peut monter directement
mais sarah lui relève des possibilités
de se montrer sur le tir extérieur
notamment
je crois qu'il a dû prendre 20 paniers à
trois points sur la saison même
peut-être un peu moins mais elles ont
pour moi c'est ça qui va pas vraiment
tout tout tout tout driver sur sur la
plaie 80 ou moins et ça oui il ay lui
arrive d'en mettre zidane n'est pas moi
c'est ce que j'ai dit 'a l'heure n'est
pas maladroit non moi c'est ce que c'est
ce que j'avais bien écrit noir sur blanc
noir sur blanc femme et à mes amis j'ai
à mes chers administrés l'avant qu'on
aille avant qu'on a de jouer à cholet
j'ai écrit noir sur blanc qui prendra
les tirs les tirs ouverts
spotter il les prend 1 iront lyon laisse
peu en général mais quand ils essayent
dé prendre il n'a pas peur d'aller
prendre là la difficulté pour pour
complémenter ce que dit alan c'est le
doublant la capacité qu'il aura enchaîné
à poser la balle au sol à faire des
choses d'une part et d'autre part le
fait qu'il est il soyez très très limité
sur sa main gauche chère qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est un joueur si vous
l'envoyez à gauche ou
si vous me forcer à avoir mon poser la
balle au sol qui peut être en difficulté
mais encore une fois c'est ce que tu dis
où j'ai pu c'est mal utilisé tout à
l'heure sur lequel je vous le disais il
joue puis cinq ans il joue depuis cinq
ans moi je n'ai je lis beaucoup vu jouer
en espoirs il ya il ya deux ans quand je
suivais régulièrement et qu'il ya neige
et autres joueurs de l'équipe là sur
cette génération il ya une progression
qu'elle aime c'est un joueur qui pour
moi
pour moi aujourd'hui il pleut il pleut
il peut jouer dans beaucoup d'équipés de
jp dit avec le même apport en terme de
temps de jeu c'est intéressant un petit
mot rapide
romain sur la gestuelle moi même sur les
trois points qu'il a mis j'ai trouvé
sauf un peu canaille a les pieds qui
partent n'importe où et c'est qu'est ce
qu'il faut corriger en priorité c'est
pas simple mais c'est toujours c'est
toujours pareil en france on a tendance
à en france par rapport à d'autres
clients attendant cette fois donc si
vous avez psy vous est pas la chance de
commencer le sport dans lequel fera
évoluer les jeunes
déjà il vous manquera toujours quelques
petites choses et surtout le fait de
pour être de pouvoir diversifier
forcément les pratiques quand on est
plus jeune c'est un pli des contraintes
aussi parfois sur le plan base sur le
plan moteur m éclate donc sur quoi
commencer mon premier jeu j'ai répondu
je m'aventure réponse sur le sujet parce
que je les ai vus ajouté mais ça on s'en
remet en creuse et le son en ont creusé
le sujet je pense tu auras toujours de
toute façon un retard qui est lié à
l'heure actuelle a fait qu'il ait
commencé l'année reparle il que les
choses sont pas totalement fixé
globalement c'est surtout de la
coordination et puis la capacité en
matière vous avez des joueurs qui
arrivent qui arrive un certain de leur
carrière à mais des tirs sans forcément
été des esthètes au niveau gestuelle le
tout c'est de réussir à équilibrer les
choses de répéter un geste qui soit le
même tout le temps et quelles que soient
les comprendre ce qu'il arrive là dessus
aujourd'hui n'a pas peur de prendre des
cires même à deux points même à deux
points
short corner sur la ligne de fond il est
capable de prendre sept chars là aussi
donc c'est pas aujourd'hui c'est plus je
dirais une
[Musique]
déjà qu'est ce qu'on lui demande de
faire parce qu'encore une fois c'est que
ce que je dis souvent c'est un joueur de
haut niveau il fait ce qu'ils maîtrisent
et yoann bakoudou fait ce qu'ils
maîtrisent il va pas se perdre sur des
choses qui maîtrisent pas donc déjà
s'est fait rentrer le tir dans son dans
son jeu petit à petit après de là à dire
qu'on peut en faire à terme un mec à 38%
trois points on va pas non plus
s'enflammer mais c'est un joueur s'il
approche si la proche des 30 des 30 32 %
déjà et qu'il arrive à mettre un tiers
par match il posera des problèmes en
plus ouais ouais pierre va aussi lui
permettent justement d'un d'attirer le
défenseur d'être une arme supplémentaire
dans son jeu puis il sera demain c'est
bénéfique pour son équipe aussi donc oui
mais pour ça faut qu'ils puissent nausée
la balle au sol pour sa foi qu'ils aient
vraiment merci les mecs ne tire pas s'il
met ne tire pas naturellement et que tu
n'as pas besoin de sortir vraiment
vraiment sur lui que tu peux rester à
deux mètres cubes ont aucun risque avec
lui si demain il est capable de
développer un premier pas et l'attaqué
fort sur son dream même uniquement sur
sa main droite
autrement que sur des lignes droites et
des choses comme ça ça devient
problématique
si tu as le tir sans pouvoir poser la
balle au sol et inversement
sur ce sur ce point je sais pas si tu as
vu le match contre gravelines romain ou
deux fois il a le son vis-à-vis qui
vient le presser vont avoir un mètre
au-dessus li na 3 poids et donc il à la
première fois il se fait prendre la
ville terrible sur le pied et puis deux
fois d'après il arrive à le dépasser ce
son premier dribble et aller et y apprit
la la la raquette qui est pour lui il va
thomas au bout quoi bein c'est parce que
c'est parce que à ce moment là sur cette
action là derrière attendait que
gravelines vient très haut il ya plus
forcément remonte derrière nous nous je
sais que dans les choses dans les choses
qu'on avait ciblé un petit peu c'était
autant qu autant que possible lui
fermait table au sol dans des finances
hier au palais où il n'y a pas d'espacé
laissé des joueurs comme ça y compris il
faut pas que des joueurs comme ça faut
qu'ils aient droit le long du bois
qu'ils puissent développer et développer
de la vitesse qui doit non seulement ce
qu'il ya de la vitesse et qui peut le
faire c'est un pierre est ce que tu peux
me parler on a évoqué des chiffres
tout à l'heure mais on n'a pas parlé à
son attitude et ses qualités de
rebondeur son importance quand même à sa
position est ce que tu peux en parler
tout un très bon très bon de tout votre
date sur quelques matches que j'ai eu
j'ai pu voir qu'il a des moments bien
peu quand même à la nage et avec le soft
à sa faible expérience
oui il peut être un peu attendre
observateurs plutôt que vraiment
impliqué aller aux boks out et suivre le
ballon chaque fois sinon c'était
vraiment au orban offensif où on sent
qu'il a peut-être un peu plus
d'appétence parce qu'il est capable avec
son envergure et sa détente d'aller de
pouvoir mettre des dépôts de bach
laissez moi ok est-ce qu'on peut
basculer du coup puisque c'est un joueur
qu'on voit depuis peu de temps au niveau
en jeep élite sur une attitude peut-être
que romain pourra nous en parler après
mais d'abord pierre est ce que toi tu tu
vois des drapeaux jaunes drapeau rouge
ou plutôt contraire quelqu'un qui a une
attitude positive sur le terrain et
aussi quand il va s'asseoir pour moi pas
de drapeaux jaunes et rouges sur
l'attitude il ya même je pense des
signes encourageants c'est sur son état
d'esprit son agressivité je me souviens
de l'avoir vu pendant la coupe du monde
il semble en 2019 avec l'équipe de
france dans un match contre la chine il
n'a pas beaucoup joué pendant le tout
championnat et sur toutes ces actions il
est vraiment à 110% à chaque fois qu'ils
donnent donc c'est une explosion
il a vraiment il a le sens qu'il va le
dribble la motivation vent pour pour
jouer au basket est dedans
il ya dans les vidéos où on le voit
s'exprimer il est aussi très très
confiant très il a l'air d'avoir
vraiment les idées en place et d'être
moment un garçon qui est bien formé
romain et sur l'attitude peut-être des
choses que tu as pu voir qu'ils sont pas
sur des vidéos
quand tu quand vous l'avez jouer c'est
une attitude professionnelle bois ce qui
est pour pour pour un pour un joueur de
son âge qui découvre le haut niveau j'en
ai vu j'en ai vu des plus agitées
globalement non c'est ça bouge pas ça
bouge pas c'est à dire parfois parfois
comme le disait bien c'est par séquences
et parfois un petit peu attentiste ou
c'est pas attentistes mais c'est un
petit peu passif mais ccc voici un petit
peu lié au manque de désir au manque de
vécu basket aussi mais c'est des choses
qui comme petit à petit moi ce que je
vois c'est que les ce qui m'intéresse
c'est la réaction c'est à dire que lille
joue pas pendant plusieurs matchs et
puis du bon moi je retrouve à jouer
balle efficace alors anecdotes anecdote
selon notre source ce qu'on ne citera
pas en fête le soir où il explose compte
mise puisque c'est ça qui s'est passé il
devait être prêté avec lendemain à
l'effort que ça et donc ça peut
expliquer aussi aux côtés réveil le côté
envie de tout l'été alors ça peut aussi
ne pas l'expliquer mais toujours est il
que du coup l'équipe a changé d'avis et
décidé de le conserver
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui qui voit
là a su réagir au bon ben ouais trop
longtemps du très sympathique qui a
répondu présent et qui a prolongé un
petit peu l'espoir l'espoir de cholet
peut être pouvoir se qualifier en bcl
sur ce match là et puis puis sur ce
qu'il a pu apporter non moi j'ai pesé
pas de neiger pas de raid fac
particulier concernant ou parce que j'ai
entendu ou par ou parce que j'en ai vu
moi je pense que c'est un joueur cas qui
a bossé cac a encore beaucoup besoin
d'être accompagné
j'ai vu les champs avec l'échangé à
synalia signer à wadi la de limoges
avait travaillé depuis plusieurs fois
sur un était absent que c'était il ya
deux ans on l'a fait beau c'est un petit
peu mandin de gants devant toural donc
c'était c'était pas une intéressant pour
le gamin de d'avoir pu avoir cette
expérience et du mois tous comment la
disco là c'est quasiment que du bien je
connais je connais plusieurs plusieurs
rues est passé par par cholet qui m'ont
dit du bien sûr le sur le bonhomme au
quotidien donc voilà c'est tant mieux
encore une fois tant mieux il faut des
joueurs comme ça absolument et surtout à
son jeune âge puisque on a le droit
d'être fou pas enneigé monsieur la tête
bien faite c'est encore mieux manu
comment tu le projette est ce que il ya
combien d'années d'être un pro à peu
près accompli c'est hyper dur comme
question mais assez simplement est ce qu
il
il faut qu'il se présente à la draft
cette année ce qu'il faut attendre et ce
qu'il faut qu'ils préfèrent l'europe qui
et comment tu vois les choses ici ma
fille continue comme ça en terme de
stades de jeu je pense qu'il faut qu'il
tente sa chance mais pour moi il doit il
doit pas aller en nba tout de suite il
faut juste à chaud - au moins deux ans
pour continuer de continuer de
s'aguerrir c'est un peu ça va être
important pour lui d'être un peu court
et d'être un peu de et trouver du temps
de jeu parce que si vous pas trop nba
s'il vous patron angelides
ça va être compliqué d'avoir une
progression et ça va être compliqué
d'avoir dix minutes pour moi il faut
qu'ils me kyi qui reste en europe pierre
toi qui couvrent un peu l'europe
continent européen
du côté des prospects
c'est ce qui est important c'est de
regarder c'est de savoir s'il ya des
profils similaires garuba est plus
avancé que lui et de toute façon plus
jeunes s'il sera pris plus haut mais
après sur les prospects qui pourraient
être des candidats
j'ai pas une fin de second tour pour
être justement draft-n stache est-ce
qu'il y en a d'autres qui pourraient lui
faire concurrence en europe il ya
khalifa dedans
on a parlé la semaine dernière qu' une
qualif à biot
ouais le podcast dernier pardon ce n'est
pas du tout la semaine pascale le
podcast dernier le et pulls et les
jeunes qui sont du côté de mes galec ils
ont là ils ont la chance d'avoir un peu
plus d'expérience je pense aux ou plus
au niveau national est haussière en
ayant des compétitions européennes il a
fait peu de assez peu de l'équipe de
france aussi
depuis qu'il a commencé assez tard donc
je le mettrais pas peut-être pas encore
au même niveau que les autres prospects
de sa génération il aura maintenant les
prochaines qui pourra encore se
présenter ça me semble limite ça peut
être un pari peut-être si sur la plaine
la saison il réussit vent - accumulé
beaucoup de minutes mais un
particulièrement en france on sait que
ça peut être la saison elle est très
très floue pour la suite de la saison
ça va être le savez une histoire de
contexte je pense mais pour moi c'est ça
peut être comment un joueur qui n'a un
prochaine peut peut-être décoller
s'imposer dans un effectif soit 2,10
pénit soit 2 d'une équipe d'eurocup et
qui pourrait aller chercher des minutes
et se faire bien voir pour les scouts
absolument
alan comment tu tu imagines on aime bien
généralement les ce cas où tu aime bien
les gens ont la cote comme ça les late
bloomer peuvent avoir la cote s'y colle
mais c'est que c'est vrai c'est vrai ce
qu'a dit pierre sueur c'était décevant
de voir faire qu'un bourreau match
contre aliot à la coupe du monde u 19
c'est le premier groupe la chine et
après ils jouaient pas
c'est hot prospect français qui jouent
et ceux qui jour augment qui nie
baptiste bat baptiste ministre qui
pâtissent toi mais elle son profil de
gaylib l'omr il est moins connu que que
des intérieurs qui sont un petit peu
plus connus ou côté d'égal en europe
comme un mars il apparaît qu'en qui joua
au stand cette année aux filous
d'ostende exactement au même mariage du
portier l'allemande qui jouant en
lituanie mais il est un peu plus vieux
mais il est où il a moins si le fait
d'être laide bloomer nuance un peu le le
fait d'être plus agités âge c'est ça a
fatigué là c'est là c'est un chiffre
mais de là je doute
à quelle hauteur commencé le basket ceci
en âge important mais ouais moi moi je
pense que moi je pense que je le draft
eux rien entre dans la deuxième partie
du second tour je pense que surtout si
une équipe de plusieurs pick & katz
tâches comme ce qu'a fait personne avec
matar même si mal bien plus évoluée que
que marc quinn do l'âme il était aux
commandes art mais ça peut être un jour
en jour dans ce type là là la chose qui
peut être un peu plus problématique
c'est que il ya beaucoup d'européens qui
sont retirés de la drogue du vin qui
joue bien en europe l'installer qui vont
y aller il y allait en 2021
bien parlé de petru cfa avait égalé
qualitatif aussi qui moi j'aurais très
vite et il est retourné en grèce il joue
au pana et je crois que ça se passe pas
trop trop mal et voilà donc ce sera à
voir je coupe à une société lui ce sera
plus aux choses
oui je crois que qualitatif annonce
héros de caveaux poulos qui a été nommé
avec makoun doux pour être meilleur
espoir
je les ai vus dans les landes et c'est à
la justice ont affronté je crois que là
le cas étaient dans la même poule que
cholet 6 g de riz giro
deux bons mois de mars voilà roman ne
viendra nous parler des prospects
grecque qui comme en conclusion une
conclusion sur notre ami makoun 12 s'il
te plaît moi je rejoins pas mal de
propos je pense que le côté les bloomers
peut plaire
je pense également que mon avis loto et
lisibilité l'an prochain je crois sans
dire de bêtises il me semble que c'est
long non la nuit d'avant cette année les
vingt trois ans 22 matchs et 2022 l'auto
lisibilité de je me perds toujours un
petit peu avec ça dure
mais par rapport à des naissances désolé
l'auto lisibilité peut être pour être
peut être quelque chose le côté stache
je pense que c'est intéressant aussi
après les arguments à faire valoir et
s'ils devaient passer suppose que je lui
souhaite parce que voilà il ya pas de
raison sur dur du deuxième partie de
deuxième tour effectivement ça peut être
ça peut être crédible
ça peut être l'année et avoir et et pour
ma part j'ajoute que on n'est pas là en
train de on pourrait nous accuser de ça
même si on n'a pas cette puissance
médiatique mais on n'est pas là en train
de faire monter la sauce pour rien c'est
juste que le gars il a fait un mois de
janvier exceptionnel
on n'est pas en train de vous dire qu'il
va aller pour sur un biais en train de
vous dire que s'il continue comme ça il
est possible qu'ils aillent
mais des voix mais d'américains qui
encore des gens qui des gens qui suivent
le compte sur des gens assez assez assez
assez clair dans leur propos est assez
assez crédible en général quand on en
parle à plusieurs reprises
voilà c'est inévitablement ses
performances ses performances de janvier
le mettre sur les radars
il n'y a qu'à voir la com
sur les réseaux sociaux quand même que
quelques joueurs intéressants dans le
casting qui propose des pauvretés tueur
modèle de course individuelle mais ce
thème en valeur et le trapèze au mois de
janvier
c'était une personne ne s'enflamme pas
et voilà pour moi un projection s'ils
continuent qui reste content et qu'il
évolue projection sur du deuxième tour
sur deuxième tour deuxième partie de
continuer ce qu'on va le sait mais
plutôt bien il est l'heure de clore le
dossier makoun doux merci à vous pour
vos différentes analyses et on va passer
à la chronique de surveillance des
rookie puisque alan tel sort on garde un
oeil sur le royaume et du coup à nous
parler d'une d'une leçon qu'on a qu'on
pourrait avoir à retirer en regardant
jouer les rookie que nous suivions
l'année dernière donc pour la draft 2001
ouais bon je voulais parler je parlais
avec aurélie dernièrement la mécanique
puisque c'est la mécanique de tir c'est
un truc qu'on on aime bien disséqué
décortiqué c'est un outil qui peut
servir à à projeter et andrée et tout
comme le type de tir pris pour le shoot
extérieur et si elle survient un peu le
début de saison brillant à deux exemples
de joueurs sur lesquels le tir pouvait
être un doute
ça l'était chez certains membres du site
sur eux je pense que sur les deux jours
dont je parle est donc là mais lowball
et harry's halliburton chaque membre du
site avaient au moins un doute sur un
des deux shoots à un des deux joueurs en
vo fait elle donc tu penses que ça
pouvait soit sur la meinau bolsas
sélection dire ce qui se passait sur son
bas du corps et frais qui changeait tout
le temps de mécanique et sur terre et
halliburton je pense que c'était
vraiment sur la mécanique pure qui
faisait qu'il est qu'il ya une
difficulté à prendre des tirs en sortie
de dribble et donc ça pouvait limiter un
peu son souffle dans cette boucle
mission que vous plongez dans les stades
de type de tir pris et de réussite sur
le début de saison qui sont disponibles
sur bois sur nba.com franchement je
conseille aux gens d'aller voir s'ils
cherchent un peu d estaing
yaya c'est très c'est assez pour ceux
qui n'ont pas les sites mastodontes
comme ge energy s'est pas trop mal et on
se rend compte qu'en fait les deux temps
des types de tir différents et dans des
contextes différents mais qui peuvent un
peu se rejoindre et pourquoi
eh ben elle nous tire ça se passe plutôt
bien l'abbé l'eau il y à 34 % à 3 mois
et il prend 70 % à peu près de 2 de
catch your death donc 30% tir en sortir
c'est assez c'est assez
ça c'est important pour un rookie et est
1 34% de réussite à trois points sur
quant à peu près en matière de télé tirs
sont des tirs compliqué des sciences
anti dribble c'est vraiment pas mal
la mécanique et les scolaires elle est
un peu problématique au canada
mais force est de constater qu'il est
quasiment 80 présent 6 francs et à 34% à
donkey donc c'était bien surtout qu'ils
sont rôles changent
il est titulaire depuis cinq matches il
joue beaucoup avec terry rosir il jouait
corps d'années voire qu'il joue avait
pigé washington mais même si elle est un
peu blessé et en fait on voit que bah
quand il a vu pareil pour halliburton
quand il joue avec fox mehdid
harrison barnes pour des roues qui est
mis sur le terrain avec des joueurs qui
sont c'est bête hein mais fort au basket
ça aide ce qui n'arrive pas à gagner
doit redouter qu'ils jouaient leur pas
bon parce que dans les allées parton lui
c'est différent
il prend 93 % de ces tirs à trois points
après une passe donc il prend 9 de ses
10 tirs à trois points qu'il prend cdu
spots du catch and shoot mais avoir une
différence définition mais c'est pas en
sortie dribbles et il y à 44% trois
ponts donc en fait c'est on peut dire qu
un libertin est un meilleur shooteur que
la meinau paul il d'un meilleur shooteur
de spotters mais c'est rarement bon
shooteur de sortie très beau mais en
tout cas ces deux joueurs qui ont pas
changé leur mécanique
ils ont toujours la même mécanique qui
avait des résultats aux lancers-francs
moyens plus mais pas mal
une mécanique aussi douteuse sur le tir
et qui en fait parce se sont
parfaitement incorporé dans un collectif
qui arrivait à vivre sentir ils ont pas
ils n'ont pas besoin du shoot pur pour
totalement peser quand on voit
halliburton serrières qu'ils passèrent
très fonctionnel à un jour qui fluidifie
très bien les actions la mêlée où on ne
savait il crée énormément de passe sur
le pick and roll c'est pour moi déjà
raté a dépassé les plus créatifs de la
ligue il on peut noter chez les deux il
joue dans le clutch
je pense que si on regarde un peu
partout c'est deux des favoris pour le
titre de rookie de l'année
mais en fait c'était intéressant de voir
que la mécanique n'est n'est pas un peut
être un frein dans le plafond potentiel
du joueur mais sur le plancher on voit
quand même que ce sont des gens qui
seront pas cataclysmique hotyat
département savait qu'ils seraient pas
cataclysmique aux tirs mais on se
demandait le type de tir qu'il prendrait
s'il serait pas munis d' immenses et
dans sa sélection
là où la mélo où il prenait le premier
détient un peu casse croûte et de loin
en australie mais donc moi j'ai vraiment
des choses à retenir c'est de leur
compas besoin du cirque pour vivre ça je
peux le dire après 20 matchs une vieille
peau qui seront des jours de rotation
sans intérêt très fort et dans le type
de tir qui prennent sont déjà malgré une
mécanique par pavone moyens donc c'est
déjà très intéressant pour repos donc la
mécanique ne fait pas tout c'est ce que
si deezer romain tout à l'heure en ont
donné quand ça tombe dedans ça tombe
dedans et tant mieux et on a des contre
exemples de personnes de joueurs qui
essayent de changer leur mécanique et ça
ne fonctionne pas quoi
jared culver brandon clark la rechange
et c'est complètement catastrophique et
les pourcentages s'en ressentent
donc c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
on avait grandi avec cette idée
peut-être en france avec cette histoire
de tony parker qu'avait petit à petit
bosser son tir changer ses mécaniques
avec chip et l'inde à san antonio
c'est peut-être plus un contre exemple
qu'un exemple l'exemple de kauai l'aude
hard également pour un joueur qui aller
encore plus haut messieurs merci
beaucoup
romain pierre manuel ânes avouent qu'ils
écoutent et merci également
est-ce que vous avez un message à faire
passer sheikh membre du podcast pour
d'aucuns devade à brec'h 320 ch me de
telenet
mettez vous sur le bord de la route
monsieur quand vous téléphonez et
couvrez vous il fait vraiment oui alors
il paraît que chez vous moi je suis plus
dans le sud de la france en ce moment
donc ça va mais il paraît que chez vous
il fait froid mais ceci dit ce podcast
paraîtra sera peut-être plus froid du
tout cela je trouve les gens exactement
les coeurs et les esprits
merci à vous d'avoir écouté on se
retrouve très bientôt sur envergure
vous pouvez évidemment aller consulter
les fiches des prospects sur envergure
coincé au tous nos podcasts y sont de
nombreux articles par exemple le dernier
en date sur les prospects de j league
écrit par alan des scouts in report avec
points forts points faibles points
améliorer bresse il ya plein de choses
plein d'informations donc n'hésitez pas
envergure penser au hainaut @ sur
twitter et instagram c'est envergure
tiré du bas pod
à bientôt tout le monde et on fait des
bisous